this is a production of Cornell
University
very much I'd like to talk about my work
a little bit at first and then show you
a few images of it you know my son Sam
he's a just went to college this year
and when he was a child he had a kids
book about three bears that encounter
urban sprawl and these bears they they
went up over a hill near their den one
morning they looked down somebody's
built a shopping center overnight well
already people are hustling and bustling
up and down the sidewalk on they all
look so satisfied well the little bears
they're not sure they're happy anymore
so somewhere they find people clothes in
the next sequence of pictures you see
these little pint-sized figures moving
amongst the legs of all the other
passers-by and the caption reads well
now that they're like everybody else are
they really happy well no not really
because underneath those people clothes
still beat their furry little animal
hearts luckily a big wind comes up it
blows into blows blows men's ties out
blows women's skirts up one big Gus
blows all the little bears clothes off
and for the first time they realize who
and what they are man they go tearing
back across the parking lot back to a
place that they could just be themselves
and it wasn't so many years ago as the
crow flies that I was getting ready for
work I had a coat and tie on in a
briefcase I start down my walkway and a
really big wind comes up and it blows in
it blows the first Gus blows my
briefcase right down the street the
second blows off my coat and tie the
third blows everything else away as I'm
standing there completely amazed at this
unlikely turbulence in my life the only
thing I could feel under those people
clothes studying them an animal heart
and I have this flashback to all these
times in my life the only thing I could
think about was giving up my regular
life going off into the distance maybe
under the wilderness and building a
small cabin and living in a more
essential way well there was a time of
change for me and I found myself at the
how to section of the library I saw
things like load-bearing our factors and
coefficients I said well you know
building a house even a small cabin
might be a whole lot harder than I
thought but luckily for me as I start
back across the library I happen to
stumble on a big stack of national
Geographics
and maybe the first one I picked up was
about the barrios in Rio de Janeiro in
which a whole segment of the population
the disenfranchised have to go out and
pick up the dendrite asst the castoffs
of urban life and take that material
somewhere and build them a place to live
so I know I'm not supposed to like these
because these are really poor people and
yet they've done an amazing job with the
material that they had at hand or maybe
it was a you know tribe from the amazon
basin who had to go into the jungle and
forage whatever was available to build
the things they needed so I know these
Hut's don't have any running water or
electricity but they're beautiful and
they look so good in the environment
from which the material cane or maybe
was a bird from africa that had done an
amazing engineering feat say well I know
these birds are not smart enough to do
this but in human terms this would be
amazing craftsmanship so it was then I
realized that maybe I wasn't a normal
builder maybe I was more of a hunter and
gather some kind of an inspiration
builder and I did get started on that
house and I learned some things that
really held me in good stead in my art
life and maybe the first is really the
simplest it's learning to accept what
you do because if you don't know much
about building you put a window in the
morning boy by noon you're totally
disgusted with yourself you want to take
that thing right out of it right out
again but to be fair to myself I decided
that each day I would try to do the very
best job I could do at the end of the
day I would accept my progress and the
next day I would build on it the second
thing is you use non-standard materials
like so many sculptors do you can't
always go to Home Depot and Lowe's and
buy the things you need and similarly if
you cut a big tree down and from the
woods and decide to use it it's the
mainstay of your house how do you know
it would work and who would you ask well
I played a game with myself I call
giving it my one best shot and I said if
there's nobody left on earth what do I
think do I think it's strong enough so
somewhere along there I began accepting
responsibility for the kinds of things
that I designed and made the third thing
is working day in and day out in a very
unselfconscious way I begin to see what
I liked and what I'd
like I saw how important personal
preferences in making those decisions
and over a period of time I began to
develop my own sense of personal
aesthetic and finally I saw how
important need was in getting anything
done I really needed this house so it
was able to coalesce my best energies
and direct my best problem-solving
skills and sometimes when I have a
sculptor friend who's not doing that
well with their work i'll say hey you
have to figure out how to need it well I
didn't know it was getting out of hand
my neighbors did and they were coming
over to my house as scratching their
head and kicking the dirt and a friend
Brooks brought us you know relative from
another area the country and he said I
really like what you're doing here
you're a real artist well maybe for all
of you that be a great thing for
somebody to say about you but for me it
felt like the edge of the earth and I
really wanted him to take it back and
upon reflection I realized that as a
child I thought being an artist was the
greatest thing you could be the only
trouble was it came with this enormous
sense of personal responsibility you
were supposed to do something great
something earth-shaking something that
saved people and it seemed like it was
connected with that onerous word talent
somehow you were supposed to be talented
well I knew what the word talent and art
had to do with Michelangelo and Leonardo
da Vinci I just couldn't figure out what
it had to do with me or anything I was
doing it my house so one shimmering
moment I found myself at the nearest art
department and rolling in our history
courses and sculpture and you know for
me that minute that day was the best day
of my life because I didn't know there
was anybody else like me I didn't know
there were lots of people who liked
material who like just handling it who
like seeing their ideas get worked out
in three dimension the only trouble was
I was an art nerd and so I'd walk around
and I'd say is this art is this art how
come this person gets to paint this
board blue and call it art that's just
about the whole fourth again when the
professor grabs me by the thread starts
choking me to death and he said who in
the hell cares if it's art or not why
don't just go in there and make
something make whatever you're going to
make who's going to know the difference
in 20 years anyway
and you know I needed that permission
giving and I learned some things while I
was in school that I think help towards
my propel me to become a working artist
and maybe the first is the importance of
a role model because I didn't know if
you had to have a psychiatrist standing
by when you made your first piece or
whether you you know had to have some
kind of great family of people like
getting a divorce or leaving your
boyfriend or girlfriend or maybe you had
to go to New York and work as a waiter
in order to qualify and it wasn't until
I saw these relatively normal people who
were really compelled about making
things that I realized there was going
to be some hope for me the second thing
is that it's hard to be a food baddest
unless there are other people around who
eat beans and rice and similarly it's
hard to be a working artists unless
there are other people around who
understand what you're going through and
the biggest my biggest challenges of
working artist is is to maintain a sense
of personal equilibrium and this is
somewhat difficult in our society that
gives high marks to culture but really
ignores individual makers and it's easy
to have an identity crisis at any time
in your career in which you walk in your
studio one morning and you can't
remember who made that work and it's
then you're glad that they're use a
university art department around or that
you have a friend at a distance that you
can call it say hey Scott are you still
working and some sometime how when he
says he is you're able to and you can
just go right on with it the third thing
that I began to see is there's a big
difference between doers and viewers
between people who make things and
people who look at them seriously and my
mind there were two different jobs you
know museum directors and curators and
gallery owners there their job is to
decide what object or person is more
inherently interesting than another you
know that's not my job I have to be true
to my materials and true to my ideas a
lot of times when I started work I don't
even know what I'm doing and if I had to
worry about whether was good or not or
whether it was art historically
significant I would really never get
started so that the fourth thing is that
I had to deal with that word talent and
although I decided to tell it was in
irrelevant it just wasn't the issue I
had the right to make what I wanted
whatever you know as much as I wanted
basically I could do as much artwork as
I could afford so at some shimmering
moment I decided to go home build a
studio and get to work now it's one
thing that you know that you have the
right to make something it's another
thing to know what you're going to make
and how you're going to make it and
luckily for me I kept up with the
University I went to a see a lecture by
a woman named Marty zelt who had been a
seamstress in her life before sculpture
and she brought to her sculpture work
velcro fasteners and zippers and cloth
and I'm leaving that lecture I say I
wonder what I already know I wonder what
simple method of joining some simple
method of technology that I might
already be familiar with in us I'm
driving back home to my house I'm seeing
all these saplings alongside the road
where maintenance crews are constantly
striving to keep them down and much like
Saul being struck off his horse on the
way to Damascus I have an epiphany sigh
say hey maybe I could use those well it
wasn't so unusual that a woodsman like
myself would see the potential of the
saplings along his driveway because
they're plentiful their renewable just
like having a giant warehouse at your
fingertips and after working with this
material for a while I realized that I
had a deeper resonance with it I'd grown
up in the woodlands of North Carolina we
have lots of underbrush and intersecting
lines and as some kids late in fields
and looked at the architectural details
of clouds I found myself studying the
drawing quality of the winter landscape
all those hatch marks in the trees all
those imagined faces surrounded by
branches up there so when I turned a
sculpture it seemed easy to co-opt the
forces of nature and play all that
natural drawings I'll add on to these
larger works the thing I had to cope
with and find out about was that that
you know what that sticks had an
inherent method of joining this is what
beavers and birds already know and that
if you pull a stick through the woods
your start out pulling it but more or
less you start really jar
and long after a while in it other words
it's got this an infuriating tendency to
tangle with other stuff and that's
really the simplest method of joining
and every stick has a little flexibility
if you flex it and you pull it through a
matrix and let it go it kind of snaps
back and holds itself in place that's
kind of the how but to what if you had
seen me at the time I could probably
spend five minutes in a museum before
running down the steps with sweaty palms
and going I think they've used all the
good ideas up or you read a magazine in
art magazine you think they'd be
exploited every material or you find out
that in the last census over a million
people in New York City alone claimed to
be visual artists you say whoa there are
too many of us but you know I love to
make things and so I just decided the
art world was going to have to lump it
you know what I say about my work is
that I I make temporary work which I
built on site from materials that I
gather somewhere nearby and one of the
unique aspects of my work is that
there's no studio doors to close in no
place to hide I'm out there in public
view and the public sees the good and
the bad of it as I go you know when i'm
on site I like representing making in a
positive way I like interceding for the
Arts and I like demystifying the process
but mainly I like reminding people that
artists are just normal people who are
looking for their rightful place in the
world of work so I'd like to show you a
few slides a few images that I have some
of my house and some otherwise let's see
if you turn the lights down for me I was
lucky enough to be able to put some
slides of the piece here and and Cornell
in the work so first of all I'd like to
show you a few pictures of my house you
know I live in a small house but the
reason I do is because i tried to use
only recycle materials in it i tried to
use the smallest footprint i could
possibly get so that i could this live
sustainably i've tried to work really
hard myself
it being you know extending the kind of
environmental message abusing less these
stones I dug in the backyard and and put
them into my wall they're not quite as
good at the bottom better at the top
because I got better as I started
working the inside is this is the better
stones you always sequence your
materials and I do the same thing with
my stick work I put the bad sticks
underneath and the good sticks on top in
this case the worst stones went on the
outside of the wall the best ones went
inside I throughout the various roof of
my house I've got all this cedar split
out that I got from my woods and you
know I really like the idea of extending
your landscape into your house and to be
able to look out windows on all sides
and see the forest outside and and also
something that doesn't have to be
painted that's always kind of just
maintains itself I've built a million
sheds for myself and other people this
one was built from all the material that
I cut where I put my house and the thing
even though it's been quite some time
because this stand this shed still
stands it looks pretty good and of
course I had to build a monument to
myself because I was afraid no one would
build it to me and this is a big laid up
stone monument about eight by eight that
sits out in front of my yard I like good
stone work it this has got no mortar in
it it's basically a combination of
features stones and little goodies and
of course my neighbors were always
providing inspiration in this case it's
called waiting it out in Maple they were
telling me what their kids left home of
course things would be better in their
lives so I have a lot of neighbors so I
I put this out in the front so they
could see themselves and I just wanted
to show you a little bit about material
this is materials outside my my studio
and if you look at these pieces you
think the lines must go on forever but a
lot of the lines we're using are really
sure
sticks and your eyes making the jump
between one line and another my friend
Scott and we're about to bring material
into this gallery and start at work
where it's a dissing subtraction problem
this was at an Indianapolis at the Heron
school they always look for material
somewhere they're not going to be used
sometimes I'm beating the bulldozer to
the stick in this case the city is
expanding its golf course and we were
able to cut these nice maples prior to
the bulldozer arriving now this is a
piece and I mean this is out in Wyoming
somebody had the thought that if they
took a bulldozer to the willow in their
lake that they would have less willow
which was a really a bad move so we were
able to go out and continue to collect
endless trailer loads of willow there
this is on in Maui on the side of the
volcano we're gathering strawberry guava
and and eucalyptus trees and some of the
hills were on there so steep that you
have to use a rope to climb to climb up
them to cut in a end up in Ireland we
gathered at a biomass farm and we
gathered willow and so this is a way
that sometimes we load and get things to
be brought over to the site and finally
here's a lot of leaks that's this was a
in richmond virginia at a botanic garden
there the Louis beginner botanic and
this just a big these are our structural
pieces laying on the ground and then we
had loads and loads of these smaller
branches at which we used and this is us
working on that piece and that this was
the final piece it was 11 pieces set in
a grid they're all diamond-shaped and so
you can go in the piece and then go in
further it so there's kind of three
levels of little little huts to go
through I just wanted to show you
something from start to finish this is
an Ireland this is a willow farm and you
know every time you cut one of these
stools you get twice as many sticks so
the stools are good for about 40 years
that
what I hear you all probably know truly
how long that lasts but so you know
willow is a great vendor but it's not
the only one up and down the east coast
lots of maple just lots of different
things that can be is usable in my this
is we always have to get the materials
over to the site in this case the city
sent a truck this is Tala community art
center I'm always interested in trying
to build something where people can
really see it they were concerned that
since they're more than leprechauns in
Ireland there's a lot of crime in this
at particular area outside of Dublin
then they were afraid somebody was going
to knock the piece down I decided to use
this tree as a center core for it and
also to use a binocular kind of
architecture that the people that are
familiar with was his Irish round tower
from the 8th to the 10th century the
monks bill these egg me dig [ __ ] mattock
kind of towers and so this was my stick
tower of talla it's about 42 feet tall
and then this was a two years later when
the piece is about to come down so the
living limbs were outside the tree trunk
and then it just so happens that the
tree had been trimmed so that it exactly
took a kind of circularity of the tower
and so we were able to pull it off this
here is an Ithaca this is another great
gathering site I know some people here
in the audience help me there they know
very well where this is but this is a
great stand of sticks we always have the
problem of hauling those sticks back to
our site this was over in front of the
Performing Arts Center and between there
in the dorm we wanted to make a
companion piece for each one of these
locust trees you can see that we've
taken and spray-painted or somebody
spray-painted for us so we knew where
all the power lines electric lines and
things were under there they allowed us
to drill into the into this Plaza
because they were going to replace some
of the concrete anyway so I try to make
a small drawing about how each one of
these seven pieces we're going to
interact with the tree then I laid out
the piece by drawing picture
a footprint of the piece and then
drilled holes where over the dots are
they're allowing us to put these
structural pieces down in the ground so
that they could help hold the whole
piece up set a scaffolding system around
those uprights and then pull the shape
we want over and then kind of work on a
structural crust on top of these things
and start really building the sculpture
from there and we had quite an elaborate
scaffolding system pretty high for as
things go and then this was our final
ideal the day of the opening well I
really appreciated all the help I had
here we had a fantastic crew and it
really went well I wanted to show you
how I work and this is at the college of
art and design and Savannah this is the
old county jail when I thought about a
piece for the county jail I thought
about escape hatches and maybe flying
carpets way to get out of jail but I
just wanted to show you how it works so
first thing is that I work structurally
whether it goes in the ground in this
case i wove into the jail bars of the
old county jail and I've got this
platform lift and I'm driving back and
forth and I kind of make a structural
base and so that it will hold on it it's
like making a canvas and then drawing so
the next phase is to kind of
aestheticizing so as I'm starting to
come up and bring the image up I'm
making these big circularity and I'm
just hanging the sticks on my structural
base so that in a way that they look
good I think mainly of how it looks at
this second phase and the third thing is
to kind of build the cosmetics of it to
go back and to fix up you don't see any
cut ends you don't see any discs
anything that interrupts the I these big
white lines are whipping around and so
it thoroughly makes a kind of great
illusion of movement and and kind of
natural forces I wanted to talk about my
work in terms of temporary because I do
temporary work and work usually one good
year maybe a pretty good year and so I
would say the line between trash and
treasure is very thin with sticks so at
window piece starts looking to
then it's time to take it down this is a
pink and white dogwood I've bent the
branches down a little bit at a time
over several days I built this kind of
container form that went on top of the
dogwood and then it bloomed out it was
look really pretty and then the leaves
came out on the surface of the of the
piece and I knew that I just had three
months it could only stay on there for
three months we had talked to a arborist
ahead of time and so at a point it had
to come down and in this case my friend
of mine and I were going to hook it to
his car and drag it to the dump so we
were just dragging the sculpture right
down the street this was at Swarthmore
College and the opportunity to work on a
tree that was going to be taken down in
two years and so this is a because of
you had this strong vertical a tree with
limbs on one side and no limbs on the
other you could weave into the limbs on
one side in and contrast it with this
strong vertical it was called
abracadabra and it's about 45 feet tall
that's it's winter configuration and
then this you know some startling take
down pictures they had a bucket lift and
they were getting up but you can see
even after two years the thing was had a
bit of integrity and would have lasted a
bit longer this was a piece and in
Denmark there are some sculpture parks
around the world where you have only you
can only use natural materials most of
the time you can only get the materials
from the park in order to work so it
promoted a lot of sculptors trying their
hand at working with natural materials
in this case this is little big man he's
seeking his own reflection in this
little pond you can climb up in his body
and look at his face and one of the
great things about it was that it
flooded half the year so it gave this
other kind of kind of epic kind of
feeling to this piece maybe some kind of
a water sprite or something coming out
my foot my father-in-law is from Norway
so he was there and he took this picture
of the of its final demise the hero has
fallen
this was at Frederik Meijer Gardens and
and if you've never been there it's a
great place for art and and plantings to
go together this was my attempt at face
jugs and there are three of them about
22 feet high they sit along a window
wall so that you could see them all year
you look at them they look back at you
it's called juggernaut and so this was
for about three years later they had a
four foot snow it came tearing down the
roof and knocked these pieces on their
butts and left him screaming in the snow
and finally this piece was at the
Botanic Garden in Clemson South Carolina
and it was the first time we used living
plants within the wall so we planted
plants in there so that they could
become a kind of talisman for what had
been there this was at the five-year
mark as some of these maples we you know
botanic gardens can offer a continuous
watering they can also offer somebody to
go around in and kind of preen it and
look at it all the time so they could do
things that wouldn't normally take place
in a regular site this was a seven year
mark of the piece you know I want to
talk about my work in terms of drawing
this is a kind of half permanent piece
that's in North Carolina at the North
Carolina Museum but everything you do
with a pencil you can do with a stick
line when you hit a piece of paper with
it's a pencil you strike it with one
weight and finish off with another
leaving series of tapered lines since
sticks are tapered they can ate those
lines and give you the ability to make
things that look like they're speeding
along or that they have animation and
they they kind of give you the sense
that maybe this is some natural force of
wind water or flow and it's all just
kind of a drawing style of using Xing
and and just different weights color you
can see how mass the color of some lines
and the
let the you know like Little Red Sticks
fall to the back here i am making the
thing this was at in sheboygan wisconsin
at there a Kohler Arts Center and I like
this piece as much as anything because
it really explores drawing these pieces
hang from the ceiling I've got big
sticks that are stuck in the super
structure of the building that are about
10 feet above the light track you can go
over and move the pieces like this it's
a red twig dogwood and willow and the
thing is that we gather them in January
and we brought them inside really quick
so they held their color perfectly and
so we had these brilliant reds and
greens that really dried out and really
looked beautiful during their entire
time there and kind of skywriting this
is a from Denmark it's a piece on the
North Sea and it was this simplicity
plus i just went across the street
gathered the sticks brought them over
and worked them into this and to this
series of poplar trees and you as an
approach you drive down the road you
take a really sharp left and you're
looking at this right square in your in
your face so you know just uh you know
working with sticks allows for a lot of
possibilities this was at the World
Trade Center early on and you know
adversity sometimes can perma be
promotive the Port Authority said you
can use sticks in the building as long
as you don't touch the walls the floors
of the ceiling and I saw these
electrician using ladders and so I went
down to Putnam bladder company barred a
bunch of ladders brought them up there
and one of the things about working on
site is the ability to adjust the scale
so you can you know if you've under done
it you can build more go get more
ladders if you've overdone it takes some
ladders away so a lot of times the
success of a piece in a public space has
to do with the appropriateness of scale
so this is a kind of a second look
through the ladders this is that the
Phillips Collection this is three floors
of sticks I'm actually out on the top of
the building
looking down through the oculus and you
know like playing off these state these
smaller mark-making with this kind of
large architectural line and so that's
about 16 foot in the middle of that
stick hole there and I had a platform
lift and I was going up and down the
three floors and putting and putting
these sticks in and a lot of times I
have to work with ongoing activities of
a space so I've learned to work without
killing the audience and and you know it
adds for a greater bit of conversation
to have we have a spotter on the stairs
I'm working on the inside of the
stairway people are talking to us the
entire time so it's really fun what I do
and allows for a lot of interaction with
the public this was at the old American
craft Museum in New York the same thing
as trying to captivate this stairway try
to activate it try to blend these kind
of whirling lines with the lines that
are evident in the architecture uh you
know I wasn't just to talk a little bit
about I use volunteers in my work at
first it wasn't so much I was I would
partner with organizations use their
goodwill and in the community to
organize the logistics at first they
would say well we all get you some
people to help gather and then it turned
out there were a lot of closet stick
gathers around who said we want to help
you why can't we help you work and so
over a period of time I've gotten really
good at letting people help me and
organizing the work in small bits and
pieces so people can plug into it easily
and really help me there's a plumber
here there's a little electric a student
a retired engineer they all came out to
help me on this piece we're working
really high everybody's having a
fantastic time sometimes they said well
how do these people know what to do and
I say well we've all been children and
children know everything about sticks
their weapon a tool a piece of a wall
magic one musical instrument so you know
all you have to do is kind of reawaken
those Inklings and adults and they're
ready to go so we we always have a make
a good go of it I'd had too many bottles
of Bordeaux and this was in France there
was some wine drew
making restaurants all around this park
so it gave me the inspiration of making
this gang of of bottles and here they
are they pretty tall look pretty good
and kind of a misty though this was at
middlebury college and I wanted to show
you this piece because I wanted to show
you how many people helped me and this
piece had to be seen from the road it
had to be able to stand up to six foot
of snow and so you know lasted a really
long time and I was grateful all the
folks that pitched in part of them
cleaned leaves part of a move scaffold
and part of them helped me with the
actual construction this is a day of me
at being at the office people are
constantly talking to me this was at the
University of Michigan and you know
people stand around they tell you
stories of their life they tell you
stories about what they like and hate
about the arts you know there there's a
kind of disbelief when you put a big
pile of sticks in the yard and they're
calling the police and those are the
same people they're inviting you for
dinner the day you leave so that
transition is as part and parcel of the
success of the work that you would see
something that you really didn't
couldn't believe is going to turn out
and then as the illusion bills and
people are more friendly to it and
finally really accepting and defending
of it and sometimes there's impromptu
parties and when we pull this away this
was in New Harmony we moved our
scaffolding out to the street and people
came running out of the barbershop with
their faces half shaved they stop their
cars bright in the middle of the road
everybody came in this little place came
over to see what what it really looked
like they had a certain amount of fear
about approaching us we had five
students helping from on the piece and
when we pull the things away everybody
came for a look-see and of course this
is an Ireland it's raining the whole
time but this the students there are a
very stalwart so no matter what you do
people are going to come and see you in
the rain a piece and had
morton arboretum in Chicago and
constantly talking to people that are
are walking up to the site I wanted to
talk about my worth finally in three
ways because I've worked with
architecture contrasting contemporary
architecture with ancient ways of
working this was at the de Cordoba and
Lincoln masked my idea about this was a
tower falling back to its origin as our
serfs hut or perhaps a haystack and so
of course you know they weren't that
happy about me getting up on the roof I
decided that I would build a mock-up of
the roof the roof is 70 feet up picked
it up with a crane and set it on there
like a dunce cap and then we had to get
up there because the line quality didn't
look that good I look too insignificant
so I had to get up there and build the
line quality up using this platform lift
and so you always start out being safe
on the platform lift and then you really
need to work on something you say the
guy we just hold my belt for a minute
and you just crawl right out on the
outside of it and get over there and and
do what you have to do and you can see
we did make it a difference and this was
in Florida at the Hollywood art culture
center a kind of interaction between
insect life in this building so I try to
build sculptures that don't interfere
with ongoing activity this was a piece
that I finished for max azria it's a
clothing store on Melrose avenues in
Hollywood and they were talking to me
about doing something for the store and
I thought well this is about cloth I'm
going to make some Paisley cloth and so
ended up covering this building pretty
profoundly with all these flying bits of
sticks and the second thing i've done is
i've worked with trees I've used trees
as a matrix on which to work this is in
Japan this tree is 400 years old it was
planted the day this little temple was
built in which I was staying and often
times in Japan the sacred trees and
these Gardens have a little rice rope
around them to signify them and so that
gave me the idea of putting this kind of
welcoming cornucopia around this kind of
ancient tree
you can see it was pretty big I used the
Burj and all of the sticks and so forth
on there and these bamboos to hold it up
these kids came to visit me put them up
in there this was a piece using lalanne
dia and in England and these LAN LAN dia
hedges look solid but if you walk inside
just inside there curtain you see this
huge architectural beautiful cathedral
like spaces in there and so I'm trying
to feature those spaces by putting
skylights in there and weaving these big
chambers inside the bush so this is kind
of how you get in the Warren and you go
in further and then you know have a good
time a piece that's in a tree was in a
tree and the universe and Birmingham
Alabama at the Museum there and a lot of
times if you put something in a tree
unless you put something low down Nate
people read up the tree they won't they
won't look up so but if you go inside
this building you see it's three floors
up and it's quite an elaborate thing I
brought the tree limbs of trees nearby
together and wove over them kind of
build this rollercoaster for squirrels
and five also used the overtones of
trees in other words not just the tree
themselves but let the tree suggest and
have an interplay with the sculpture
this was down in Savannah and using this
live oak tree and the sense of mothering
by all of these bigger limbs above the
small limbs and having all the moss and
stuff drop down on to this little
architectural folly and then why this
monkeypod tree one of my favorite trees
it is just one leaf wide and using the
trunk itself as a kind of a model for
how to make these pieces work underneath
the tree and then they go up and work
themselves like bookends over the limbs
and into you know sets and a piece in
New Harmony Indiana you saw that when
people got excited and ran over there
but this was its more formal view they
it's a hornbeam hedge
and so there was a lot of room up under
the hedge it gave me the idea of
building this kind of cliff dwelling up
underneath the hedge and you can see how
successful it is in the winter it has
all this verticality then so you got
really great contrast between winter and
summer it's right in them on the commons
and this little town using a tree to
help hold the heads up of these things
called trailheads they've got their
about 35 feet tall they were each head
uses one one tree to hold it up and a
kind of elaborate shoulder system to go
inside that's a when the third thing
that I've done sometimes there's no
trees to work into there's no
architecture to glom onto you just have
to make things that stand in a certain
place this was in Brittany I built a
kind of an earth saving turtle it's got
the world on its back and a kind of
elaborate thing but it had to stand
there so i used the saplings that go in
the ground to make a big stabilized
situation in order to work and this was
a place that i was working at it's a
kind of a place of an estate that the
state owns and has turned into an art
situation this was at the morris
arboretum in philadelphia you know it
started out as a snail shell from my
garden and then it became a layer cake
and then I said no it's a Japanese since
14th century hairstyle finally I said no
it's dr. Zhivago in the Summer Palace so
I have lots of thoughts about things as
I move and kind of organize my thoughts
as as I build something a piece that I
made as a private Commission in North
Carolina that has just come down I
called it hocus pocus they wanted to
call it the thumbs up but anyway I
wanted you to look inside and see they
wanted to call it the petticoat palace
so I couldn't deal with it but anyway
you can see that this is nothing but
sticks there are no wires there is no
string it's just a infernal power of the
stick
to tangle that's holding this big piece
together a piece and Brussels sometimes
I have to work inside I still have to
make things that stand up they can't
touch the walls or be supported that
this is called sleepwalking and it's
based on a kind of a tripod look kind of
thing kind of elaborate but anyway it
worked a piece at Purdue that's still up
that maybe just has come down that was
based on on the these serpent mounds
that the first peoples in the Ohio
Valley built and so this is looking at
it from the top of the building it was
just such a great piece to experience a
piece at Bowdoin College I've learned to
hook things together at the waist to
fight the potential of weather and deep
snow to push something down in other
words you have to make something that
can stand up under the conditions of the
place this piece is up in at Winthrop
right now in South Carolina Winthrop
University it's outside of a performing
arts center called ain't misbehaving at
five faces that look down different
streets look different ways up he said
was at the museum of glass and using a
kind of imagery that might be made in
glass or clay and extending that image
using the reflection in the pond and I
really wanted to show you how many
people would come to see a sculpture
burned and and that this is in Ireland
and Scotland you know they their
fire-prone their their druids and so
that they are being the whole county
came and they knew one Europe before
that they were going to set it on fire
and they had that that's the piece it
was a great piece it was made after the
calendar standing stones and this is you
can see the scale on these pieces they
were made from willow that was collected
from this farm that I was working on and
this was that fatal night this is the
next morning that's what a sculpture
looks like when it's gone vaporized and
then these guys had the nerve to cook
their breakfast on my sculpture
thank you very much sat we have any time
so I rushed I rushed through that so
we'd have a few minutes for questions
don't be shy hey listen we're working
down at the cyclist afternoon over at
the Children's Garden we're going to try
to pull off a workshop on Friday where
people can just come up and work on it
and refine the set up a smaller thing a
little installation that people could
just come work on with us so we're going
to be there from two to four this
afternoon and we're going to be there
tomorrow from nine the name tomorrow
we're going to work and then fighting
all day and it's going to be able to
children's guards so if you want to play
around with sticks
well usually they bring a chipper
they'll bring a chipper at the end
they'll ship it on sometimes they try to
take it away in the night so that
there's nothing much controversy I was
trying to take that one foot the big
heads at the Museum down and we had an
insurrection the mud is from the
neighborhood around the sculpture park
came in a big group because we're going
to tell the artist on you have the
artist that they're making you take it
down and I'm really really sorry so you
know it's not what God made that some of
these things come down because you could
get very fond of them but they need to
come down while they still look and I
rarely get to go back and look at things
i do see follow-up pictures and it's
amazing how many pictures of a pc or on
the web so you can i can see what people
think of it just simply by going back on
him you know googling something i'll see
drafts of pictures about an individual
piece so nicely it's open up no they
shouldn't blinded yo you get one great
year in one pretty good year some places
like if you have a children's garden of
the one in Sausalito into the Brooklyn
the golden gate bridge there's a nice
children's museum there they kept one
for seven years and they just work on it
mess with it and renew it and it turned
out good pretty good please generally
stick scam facts that may just get
riddle they start talking are you to
have to use them you know what a lot of
other in play and you know I true a lot
of times I think it's better to have a
series of sculptures in a place so that
you could present a lot more ideas
because my theory is that sculptures
have ideas embedded in them and so once
general public has look come to
accommodate those ideas the sculpture
becomes lessons so having a raft or
number of sculptures one right after
another every show we're really allows
for a lot more thinking a more
provocative interplay with the public we
start out by pulling the shape with
wrote the name as we go we cut it off
and so it just holds itself together
there's no way during any no ropes or
anything annum it's better if it's
thorough it has more kind of substance
of ability to make if we can build
something it's thoroughly sticks that
holds itself up that has in here another
to join me um there's some really good
shots like pictures in in that slide
show did you take both of them or did
you just kind of collect them from like
the internet well I have an agreement
with my sites and what I do is I ask the
sites to take the photos because they
need them to the photographer has their
copyright they sign the right for us to
use it anywhere you want so it's never
been just one desire it's been numerous
job person in a way I think that some
what is believed that they can take the
best shot with their work that no one
else could see it like they do my theory
is that I don't use a camera every day
so I'm not really thinking I have more
in my mind where I think
not really is so you know having
somebody that is realistic about what
they think they can get an image yes
it's turned out any more satisfactory
complete look at the cap they do a good
job of capturing the other piece but if
they did whether they can capture the
real essence of the case but truth is
letters only go so far and I think if
you if you see a photo of reason that
you would go and experience what you see
how lacking a photo is you know it just
documents something and allowed me a
different work unfortunately the only
way to get the sense of the pieces just
to go and experiences and to can have
the associations that you might that
might for me and I promoted you when
you're talking through it and thinking
about it and seeing how it really has a
reciprocity limits site in commerce with
full side of the scale
Moorthy building I started out with clay
and did my dissatisfaction was play is
that the further process it and I really
wanted it working large I was building
these really huge large today to play
tiredness is not working out but what
this is another kind of rebirth this is
a it's got the flexibility the
pliability of working with clay and you
know it's kind of fundamental and you
can be taken from the site just like
playing is often taken from the sky by
early people that use on this fire free
hearing the source of it it right over
there you know so I like that connection
with site and then I like the way that
you can mark plan can hit it mark it
easily when it's in its quest thing and
the same thing is that you know
translates to all these market is always
mark making but you're doing on the
surfaces of these of these big stick
well it's fast and furious at the
children's garden because it's really
not going to be a my work it's going to
be a workshop in which other people get
a chance to work we had to set out
something we wanted something that kids
could ultimately use and go through that
we've settled on us a grouping of five
kind of shapes that are interacting with
columns to go between you and and we got
turns out there's a big bunch of
pumpkins that are sitting on the site
that will make absolutely great models
as people come to help us save those and
see what we can to example can bend
these shapes you know when you're first
starting them and people haven't really
worked with Styx ago you can't give them
too big of a test they have to have
simple shapes to work on so these are
very simple often shapes that rank that
we've derived because we [ __ ] as we're
on our site and looking really pretty
good
or
so I think there needs to be a
consistent line logic between inside and
out and if we walk into a we realize
that you're kind of walking in and
carrying the lines are carrying you and
your finishing company and the inside so
there's a lot of consistency and when I
use volunteers a lot of their work on
the inside of these words just an
enormous amount of detail work to get it
because you've got to think cosmetics
you've got to think the same here is
because they can't jagged stick all over
the place evening and smooth beautiful
flowing interior as well so that the
people using these look nice actually
generating they do have a beautiful look
at their you know they did generation or
process would you just have to be
careful because in public you know the
public is not as forgiving as an
individual might be in seeing entropy
you know they might like yeah what was
that the first person see they have
giant pile of dirt sticks that was it
so I just I leave it up to my concerts
and they want those things to you know
to go to dust they can do a good date
which would feel like you can make you
no shame for having fun yet fell down
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu